[Music]
I'm just gonna wait until we get home
where the food isn't decomposing well
la-dee-da I didn't realize this with a
bunch of sophisticates families can come
in all shapes and sizes that's why I
also feature having some two-legged
children imagine me and our future
children frolicking I think he's getting
the hang of it
Tommy so those are mr. McGregor's I
swear if it wasn't for me just Tomatoes
alone you have everything else honestly
my kids would be so much better behaved
Billy is the onion as soon as they have
a baby we've done for maybe we're better
off without them don't stare at the
scenery rushing by look at a fixed point
on horizon and just lock your eyes onto
that
I love this place what's lunch there's a
magical place with the righteous
radishes the sweetest corn it's called
the farmers market and if you want an
overpriced gift that will never be used
there so lavender scented bath bombs
this sounds a bit dodgy I would never
put you in danger
I promise okay I can't promise we're
gonna go and rob this place you in are
you out
let me go my family's in trouble and I'm
gonna get them back the other rabbits
were taken and the pig in the Hedgehog
Club and the Badger
what are you even helping me what did
that does it
[Applause]
[Music]
Varner Cottontail just discovered sugar
we had
[Music]
via gathered here today to join me and
thomas in holy matrimony
you're taking this so well he's a good
man you hated this guy we've grown very
close welcoming a new parent not that
close so father father father no you're
not my father
it's really the rabbit story I just
wrote it down
look it's Peter Rabbit oh I hate that
I'm the face of this he's naughty what I
knew Peter that depends who's asking
Peter told you he has it in for me he
was talking to all of us I'm talking to
you Peter
specifically stay out of trouble if
that's who they think I am maybe I'd be
better off without them
[Music]
oh come on
[Music]
what are you looking at goody-goody you
returned me I'm no tutti goody
apparently I'm a fatty fatty is your
name Peter Rabbit yeah I was best
friends with your dad my name is
Barnabas you're a fierce bad rabbit just
like where are the rabbits back in their
burrows snug as a bug in a rug
spread out
[Music]
still in them bullet and that's why
adults shouldn't do kid stuff
[Music]